diwala a busy coastal city in Cameroon
these fuel tanks belong to sonara the
country's National refiner and one of
several African companies glencore
admitted to bribing for preferential
access to oil money that could have been
better spent
Glencoe is a big corruptor The Firm
recognized this they said we confessed
that we corrupted people in Cameroon in
two companies SNH and sonara we paid
around 10.6 million US dollars in bribes
that's money that didn't reach the state
coffers for our development so we can
have water electricity roads and
healthcare for us and our children there
were other companies like sonara and
other countries like Cameroon in
Equatorial Guinea Ivory Coast Nigeria
and South Sudan the behavior was similar
prosecutors at Southern Crown Court in
London said glencore's UK subsidiary
paid middlemen to fly cash in private
jets across Africa to bribe officials
glencore pleaded guilty to seven charges
and was ordered to pay 310 million
dollars
largest criminal penalty ever handed
down
first time there to a corporate has been
prosecuted under section one of the UK
bribery that essentially means
that they weren't just guilty of failing
to prevent riber if you will but
actively authorizing bribery the company
and its lawyers are apologizing
Claire Montgomery one of glencore's
legal representatives in court said that
the company's Behavior was inexcusable
that it had no place in glencore but
that these practices do not happen in
any form in glencore companies today but
this case isn't the last of glencore's
legal problems it set aside 1.5 billion
dollars to settle a series of global
investigations including about 1.1
billion dollars for U.S authorities Rory
challenge altazira London